here's what I want to point out to you
this method of going through and
everything it's nice it helps you
understand what is going on but there's
a problem namely boy doesn't take a long
time and you guys nerd you guys know how
famously lazy mathematicians are we're
always trying to do but no matter what
now you have a look at this cleaning
there are patterns everywhere so how can
we take advantage of it here's what I
want to point out to you have a look at
this middle column in here you have a
look at it now is there a way I could
just go through this middle column and
just go through one number to the next
and not worry about doing all of this
extra stuff as a separate set of
processes he's the one I'm gonna do it
when you think about how we got from the
first year to the second year we started
with this amount we calculate the
interest which was lost by by 2006 and
then we added on the original amount
that that's simple right so you add on
one little one one off this original map
I can do both of those at once right we
actually had a look at this back when we
were doing any money why do you remember
this in Saigon you want to work out
you're dumped by every time I walk you
put all your hours in together and then
you multiply by your hourly French okay
see exactly the same time now if you do
this you do 2400 times I mean I can do
anything
look at that I can just say that's 1.36
and your campaign who's gonna hand that
to you 2544 right away okay now from
there this process here this one here
that's just what takes me from one year
to the next one so if I took 2,500
multiply two by hacked 1.06 it's gonna
give me that two six nine 664 etc and
one last time if I go and I actually
want you to get your calculator out if
you haven't put it away already and just
confirm for me if you do this two six
nine six and 64 cents and you multiply
by one point oh six I'm expecting some
rounding to happen because that's what I
had to do here right if I remember my
numbers right it should change you into
eight five eight and four three blah
blah blah which rounds up to four four
so here's what I want to point out three
years we did the same persist three
times or multiplied by this then we
multiplied it again then we multiplied
it again right so by taking simple
interest repeatedly that's what gives us
this the actual amount right the amount
I interval applause the principle what I
started doing and then you do this
multiplication three times right you
multiplied by one plus what was that
point zero six what worked at that
controlling the question it was the rain
right that week hold that off from the
original right and we did it three times
right
why did it what happened three times the
answer is there were three years right
it's whatever number of time periods
you're looking at now this is the
familiar compound interest formula so
you
met last year it's got the same three
pieces principle right and a number of
time periods but because we're doing
something different mathematically
that's why it's arranging a different
way to this okay
well its first up because it shortcuts
this whole process it takes you straight
from here to this final map but a would
point out they give you something
different from the simple interest
formula right it gives you the total
amount that you're in with is 2,000
whatever figure out where is the simple
interest formula is just telling you
that 432 that you got the end that's
just the interest right and you can
check out 2400 times 0.06 times 3
it'll give you 400 that you just like we
have